deux questions numéro 3 139 de monsieur
philippe bas madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est une question qui récurrente que je
voudrais vous poser madame la ministre
nos associations des aides à domicile au
service des personnes âgées sont dans
une situation aujourd'hui très difficile
elles ont pour ce qui concerne les
personnes dépendantes prise en charge au
titre de l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie
le bénéfice d'un tarif qui est d'un euro
50 plus élevé que le tarif horaire qui
est proposée par la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et donc par ses
correspondants régionaux pour la prise
en charge de l'aide ménagère pour les
personnes âgées et les moins dépendantes
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation très compliquée car une grande
partie de nos associations dead à
domicile assume ses prestations en étant
couverte en dessous de leur coût de
revient nous les avons incité à se
regrouper
ce qu'elles font elle économise des
frais de gestion mais ça ne suffit pas
et la question que je vous pose est la
suivante puisque jusqu'à d'or aucun
fonds d'urgence n'a permis de régler le
problème soit vous arriverez à mobiliser
des crédits nouveaux types de l'aide
sociale de la caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et de la
mutualité sociale agricole et à ce
moment là vous pourrez augmenter le
tarif horaire de nos associations pour
qu'elles ne meurent pas soit vous ne
pouvez pas le faire dans les
circonstances financières actuelles mais
à ce moment là il faudrait que vous
puissiez autoriser les associations dead
à domicile financé par
l'assurance vieillesse au titre de
l'aide sociale à percevoir la différence
entre le coût de revient de la
prestation et ce qui est pris en charge
au titre de l'aide ménagère de l'usager
lui même qui ne demandent pas mieux dans
la plupart des cadres de financer mais
vous ne pouvez pas à la fois refusé de
financer le nécessaire et refusé que les
associations se finance en obtenant
lapointe de la part des personnes âgées
qui sont assistés si vous êtes dans ce
double refus alors nos associations des
deux à domicile pour les plus fragiles
d'entre elles vont disparaître avec le
coût social que ça représente pour les
personnels qui que ces associations
emploi mais surtout la difficulté pour
maintenir la priorité que vous partagez
avec nous j'en suis sûr au maintien à
domicile de nos personnes âgées
voilà à la fois la question que je veux
vous poser et l'inquiétude que je relaie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur philippe bas il est
incontestable que les associations aides
à domicile rencontrent des difficultés
et tout élu local est confronté sur son
territoire à les inquiétudes qui peuvent
être portés par ces associations dont le
rôle doit être reconnue et saluée au
service des personnes âgées pas
seulement d'ailleurs des personnes âgées
mais notamment des personnes âgées et si
nous voulons favoriser le maintien à
domicile de ces personnes pour préserver
le plus longtemps possible leur
autonomie nous devons bien évidemment
agir c'est ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
en décidant de créer un fonds de
restructuration à l'aide de l'aide à
domicile dans la loi de finances pour
2013 et ce fonds permettra de mobiliser
50 millions d'euros pour l'année 2013 et
l'année 2014 qui viennent s'ajouter à 50
millions d'euros qui ont été versés en
2012 les arrêter
et précisant les conditions dans
lesquelles la répartition de ces fonds
va être effectués ont été publiés
récemment et les services ont jusqu'au
30 avril donc à la fin de ce mois ci
pour adresser leurs dossiers de demande
à l' agence régionale de santé qui
coordonne le travail administratif en
liaison évidemment avec l'ensemble des
financeurs en particulier les conseils
généraux et les caisses d'assurance
retraite et de la santé au travail c'est
donc auprès des agences régionales de
santé qui convient de s'adresser et le
travail d'instruction des dossiers va
être réalisée en concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs mais sous la
responsabilité de crs cette première
action importante et volontariste se
poursuivra il s'agit d'élaborer une
stratégie de refondation de l'aide à
domicile qui nous permettent de répondre
notamment aux exigences de qualité de
professionnalisation et d'accessibilité
financière pour les usagers et nous
permettent également de satisfaire aux
exigences de bonne gestion des crédits
mobilisés
nous allons engager des expérimentations
pour déterminer un nouveau mode de
tarification qui devrait permettre de
mieux définir les prestations qui sont
attendus et définir les modalités d'une
contractualisation par chaque conseil
général avec les opérateurs qui
interviennent sur son territoire sur son
territoire l'idée étant que dans chaque
territoire il puisse y avoir une
contractualisation à partir d'objectifs
spécifiques partir évidemment d'un cadre
national mais d'objectifs spécifiques
dans un cadre pluriannuel
un groupe de travail sur les gir 5 et 6
qui relèvent actuellement de la cnav de
la caisse de retraite et de la caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse devra
également permettre de favoriser le
recours à
à l'aide à domicile pour les personnes
qui sont encore largement autonomes mais
qui commence à perdre cette autonomie
avec l'idée de faciliter la transition
en cas de passage au gir 4 vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement est
pleinement conscient des préoccupations
que vous évoquez que vous relayer et il
a d'ores et déjà pris des mesures afin
de répondre à la situation auquel sont
confrontées les associations d'aidé à
domicile
merci madame la ministre monsieur
philippe bas je vous remercie et madame
la ministre de votre réponse et de
l'intérêt que vous portez à nos
associations d'aidé à domicile et avant
tout naturellement aux personnes âgées
qui bénéficient de leurs prestations
je voudrais tout de même vous dire que
malheureusement le fonds d'urgence de 50
millions même renouvelé chaque année ne
s'est pas révélée jusqu'à présent la
hauteur du besoin et je suis je reste
préoccupé après votre réponse des
conditions de l'équilibré financier de
nos associations
j'avais dans ma question
était jusqu'à demander si vous pouviez
envisager de desserrer les contraintes
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est nullement une
contrainte légale qui empêche de
percevoir un complément de la part de la
personne âgée elle-même quand le tarif
pour des raisons budgétaires et
financières nationales est bloqué à un
niveau insuffisant sur ce point vous ne
m'avez pas répondu mais je ne doute pas
que la réflexion du gouvernement va se
poursuivre en tous les cas vous comme
nous les conseillers généraux comme le
gouvernement et les agences régionales
de santé le conseil d'administration de
la caisse nationale nationale
d'assurance vieillesse comme celui de la
mutualité sociale agricole ne peuvent
pas laisser en état une situation qui ne
cesse de se dégrader car les
associations ont pris déjà un certain
nombre de mesures de gestion de bonne
gestion et d'économie et elles sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation où les
marges d'amélioration sont de plus en
plus faibles il n'en reste sans doute
dans tel ou tel département je peux vous
assurer que dans le département de la
manche la situation est aujourd'hui
extrêmement tendue et je ne doute pas
que vous serez obtenir de votre collègue
ministre délégué au budget qui connaît
bien département les assouplissements
nécessaire pour l'ensemble des
départements français
car il doit avoir lui aussi conscience
de cette difficulté